your friends with Woodly your friends
would ask her and you know everybody
would say hey both of them took a dive
with the fight
yeah the Jake Paul fight what are your
thoughts on that I I don't know I
honestly haven't talked to either of
them about it I don't think it's
probably it's probably a sore subject
for both of them
um I don't think it was a a dive I could
be wrong no I don't know watching Jake
because now you know people were
criticizing him first fight second fight
third fight so you're kind of like
saying this guy kind of knows what he's
doing and he's training and he's kind of
do you think he's got a trajectory or do
you think Silva's gonna expose him and
it's going to be like no this is it it's
done with I think he has a trajectory I
think he's very young in the sport I
think it it's still you can be you can
be
you can be somewhat critical of the fact
that yes he has not fought any
high-level boxers whatsoever and also
sing his Praises that he does look
pretty decent for a guy who is going out
there and fighting he's he can move he
he can move he's got fast hands he's
bigger than I he's much bigger than I
thought I didn't know how big I've never
seen Jake Paul did not doesn't follow
him until these last you know couple
years in a couple fights and you see him
standing next to Anderson Silva towering
over Tyron Woodley towering over Ben
he's a bigger guy than I thought
um so he's big he's 200 something pounds
so I think uh I still think Anderson
Silva beats him but I also thought
Tyrone will beat him I thought Ben might
be able to beat him so and this is
purely boxing they're not they're not
doing any MMA but is what's his name uh
Anderson's Villa is not a boxer though
right uh he's boxed a couple times now
he boxed uh what Julio Cesar Chavez Jr
son son the son which by the way he's at
one point it was nasty oh no question
yeah he has hands bro yeah no questions
Tito Ortiz I just with my because I get
it they're fighting older people that
are you know done and it's not even
though they're not boxers the the fact
that they were they were hinting at
going to the MMA I would I would love to
see them fight somebody in the mm like
if they switch to you like not UFC but
you know what I mean try to fight
somebody's gonna put your hands on you
they would they wouldn't last I don't
think they would last 30 seconds in a
fight with like an MMA fighter forget it
but that's everything Jiu Jitsu boxing
wrestling they there's nowhere to run in
that cage bro I would I would agree with
you but I would add a caveat to it okay
here's what the caveat is
ish
never bet against somebody with a big
chip man like if the if there's a chip
and the willingness to get in there and
you know improve
you know so there's yeah there's certain
people that that do really well with
that chip there's certain people that
love the fact that everyone's like
thinking he's going to lose 90 of people
besides his couple you know not couple
of his his large contingent of YouTube
followers or whatever all of us think
he's not going to be good he's going to
lose to this guy he's going to lose to
that guy he loves that both brothers are
athletes yeah you know and some of the
some of the best people in the world in
any business they do well with you not
thinking they can pull it off yeah
they're weird like that the average
person is going to be like yeah maybe
you do have a point you're right I don't
think I can't beat them oh [ __ ] they're
right I'm not going to win this fight
and versus some are like what did you
say yeah oh really okay can you record
that video and put it on my screen saver
on my phone I wanted to every time it
rings I want it to be his voice saying
what he just said right there yeah yeah
and every time the phone rings I don't
think he can beat them hey Mom what's up
why are you pissed something because
they said I can't beat them every time
you come honey I just want to check on
you is everything good you know it's
hilarious I think Jake is in that camp
and I think his brother's in that camp
but we're gonna see we're gonna see
what's gonna happen there I think it's
gonna be a show so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]